[Música]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vieron qué maravilla
y ahora sigue la maravilla maríajosé
[Aplausos]
y
i
[Música]
y
ah
a
[Música]
y
ah
i
[Música]
no
y
i
más
[Música]
y
e
[Aplausos]
felipe compañeros
lo volvieron a hacer
muchísimas gracias qué felicidad de
estar aquí muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos y gracias a roberto por
esta oportunidad
cuéntenos qué fue lo que nos tocaron
bueno yo toqué un fragmento de la
polonesa aeróbica de frédéric chopin yo
toqué un fragmento de la rapsodia
húngara número 8 de franz liszt
baby que ustedes participan en montones
de competencias torneos no sé cómo
seamos como hacen todo el mundo toca la
misma pieza no señor normalmente
presentamos diferentes piezas a veces
del mismo género de música del mismo
estilo musical pero siempre diferentes
piezas y se juzga conforme a la
capacidad interpretativa
los días pico y que es subjetivo si en
su momento es objetivo por eso
normalmente hay una variedad de jueces
porque los jueces siempre miden más que
en tu habilidad técnica en tu capacidad
de interpretar la música en tu propia
manera para que los los oyentes también
puedan captar lo que vos querés
transmitir por medio de lo que estás
tocando como escogieron gusta de las
piezas de hoy sinceramente en mi caso
fue solamente un interés muy grande por
tocar esa pieza me fascina probablemente
algunos la reconocieron es muy famosa y
estoy súper contento de haberla
interpretado para ustedes si yo iba con
ya mis profesores yo les dije como bueno
quiero tocar narración gra y ellos me
sugirieron esta y yo les dije que sí
y ustedes sólo tocan música clásica no
sé bueno estamos aprendiendo casi
siempre hemos tocado música clásica pero
también podríamos tocarles algo popular
pues pudiera experimentar con los
géneros
y doy gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
pero
un aplauso para felipe castillo
[Música]
ah
fly me to the
moon the stars la misiva de spring isla
júpiter o mal
y no dudosa
aún más
y no deber
baby
maikel pérez sonia de místico el fondo
yo ha dado un fútbol a
juventud
vivir
i
feliz
[Música]
de algarve son de mi
amor
[Música]
vendo todo
prisma
y no
más
[Música]
y dios
[Aplausos]
[Música]